now if you thought that prime minister's
questions could get a little bit tense
just take a look
at this clip from a council meeting in
cheshire
you have no authority here jackie weaver
no authority
at all she just kicked her mouth
no no don't she kicked him out don't
this is a meeting called by two
counsellors
illegally they now elect a chairman you
know the cop because of ice chairs here
i take charge read the standing orders
read them and understand them
well it would appear that jackie weaver
did think she had authority because that
was the very moment that the chairman of
hansford's planning and environment
committee
was then removed from the zoom call last
december the recording
from that meeting all 18 minutes of it
has gone
viral well jackie
weaver the council host who made that
decision has been speaking disguised
katarina vertotsi
to explain exactly what happened at the
now notorious meeting
these things don't start on the night
they start before
and for me um you know democracy is
is hugely important i mean it starts
with town and parish councils
you had um three councillors who had
done all the right things
you know they follow all the rules and
they still weren't getting it
yeah so they had tried to get the
chairman to call a meeting
he refused um they asked him in his
capacity as clark
to hold a meeting he refused
so they exercised their right under the
1972 act
for two councillors to hold a meeting so
they put a lot of effort in
to trying to make this meeting happen
and they'd done all the rights and for
me that's hugely important they've done
the right thing
you know they hadn't just come in and
said you know we'll ride roughshod over
everything and we'll hold this meeting
they've done all the right things and
then we have
um the chairman who comes in and says
i'm not in effect i'm not going to allow
this meeting to take place
and you don't have an awful lot of time
to process what's going on at that
moment it's happening immediately
and i did what i felt was the only thing
that i could do
to enable them to hold this meeting
otherwise it would have been shut down
hence putting the three counsellors
ultimately
in the waiting room where they left
i mean you know they had the opportunity
to come back into the meeting if they
wanted to participate with the meeting
but they didn't want to participate in
the meeting they wanted to stop it
you know i did expect it to be a tense
meeting
i never expected to see behavior like
that
i mean the idea of tensions within you
know
a um you know local democracy is not new
i mean it can't have been doing this job
for that long i think everybody just
gets on really happily
but i've never seen anything like that i
don't think an apology would mean a
great deal to me i think what i would
want
is some kind of recognition from them
that maybe they didn't do the right
thing i wouldn't even put it as far as
an apology
um but just some kind of recognition we
could have done that differently
that would be good do you think gender
has
a role to play in their in the tenor
of how they were expressing themselves
i think it's difficult to think that it
didn't
um i i mean that there are a number i
haven't memorized the whole thing yet
but i think there are a number of
occasions where they certainly refer to
me in a very derogatory way
um so that you know it's hard to say
that no
sex doesn't play any part in it i think
it probably does
how does it feel to now be in this this
strange position of
having you know the world feeling like
you know go jackie you either
i think it's the go jackie weaver is is
um you know i kind of feel with that
yeah until something happens different
tomorrow which is more exciting
so i'm not quite sure it's gone to my
head but that's with tomorrow